alors les yeux de la planète sont
vraiment arrivés sur ce qui se passe en
ukraine à kiev en particulier notre
journée de chaos dans les rues de la
capitale le bilan officiel fait état de
75 morts d'autres sources parlent
davantage de morts plusieurs dizaines de
blessés depuis mardi une délégation de
ministres européens sur place pour
tenter de mettre un terme à la crise
tenter de négocier notre envoyé spécial
est arrivé alexandre chasse qu'à
la trêve annoncée par le président a été
de courte durée depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale l'ukraine n'a
connu deux journées aussi sanglante sans
qu'on sache vraiment qui a commencé les
manifestants les forces de l'ordre des
tireurs embusqués se sont mis à l'oeuvre
tuant des dizaines de personnes la
police anti-émeute s'est même servi
d'armes automatiques bientôt des
cadavres et des blessés jonchaient le
sol tout autour de la place de
l'indépendance le fameux my dad que des
centaines de milliers d'opposants au
président ianoukovitch occupe depuis
trois mois voit les milieux pour
logement extremis de prod aux jeunes pop
les extrémistes continuent à attaquer
c'est pourquoi j'ai donné certains
ordres admis le ministre de l'intérieur
ukrainien j'ai équipé les policiers
d'armes de combat réunis en session
extraordinaire le parlement du pays
tentaient tant bien que mal de trouver
une sortie à la crise en demandant la
création d'un nouveau gouvernement
pendant ce temps là devant l'édifice du
conseil suprême un des leaders de
l'opposition le boxer vitali klischko
lance un appel poignant bretagne plus
jouer
nous devons arrêter le bain de sang at
il dit peu importe les conditions le
sang doit arrêter de couler et pendant
que le président recevait les émissaires
de l'union européenne les ministres des
affaires étrangères de la france de
l'allemagne et de la pologne les balcons
ti sifflé et les opposants
reconstruisait les barricades
alexandra vous êtes arrivé aujourd'hui
d'abord j'aimerais vous demander j'étais
à quelques pas de la place de
l'indépendance où j'ai eu lieu ces
manifestations là ce que c'est calme
quelle est la situation actuellement
c'était calme patrice il ya une heure ou
2 g/t sur maïdan j'ai fait un tour
pendant une heure et demie il y avait
beaucoup de monde des gens à porter de
l'eau des gens apportaient de la
nourriture de lait sans souci pour des
cocktails molotov des pneus pour les
brûlés éventuellement pour se séparer de
la police si vous voulez on voyait pas
de policiers donc c'était assez calme et
il y avait beaucoup de monde tout à
l'heure on a entendu des tirs mais on
n'est pas retournée sur la place donc on
sait pas d'où ça venait les tirs mais on
entendait des tirs on vient de voir
juste avant ces images donc deux feux on
a vu des images en direct de la place où
ça semble relativement calme et on a vu
également des images de cette délégation
des ministres de l'union européenne qui
tente de d'infléchir le président en
tout cas et est-ce que ça ça se poursuit
ses négociations
les négociations se poursuivent patrice
c'est très important les ministres sont
arrivés ici les ministres des affaires
étrangères français allemand et polonais
il devait rester quelques heures il
reste jusqu'à demain je viens de lire
sur le compte twitter du ministre
polonais des affaires étrangères que les
négociations sont dures mais qu'ils vont
continuer il négocie éventuellement un
nouveau gouvernement des élections
anticipées
tout est sur la table apparemment alors
il se promène entre l'opposition et le
palais du président pour négocier pour
arrêter justement ce bain de sang et en
même temps on a décidé à bruxelles on a
décidé un gel des avoirs et des visas
qui seront imposées à ceux qui ont du
sang sur les mains face par rapport à
ces massacres qui ont eu lieu lundi et
aujourd'hui on voit pendant qu'on voit
laurent fabius donc qui fait partie de
la délégation bien sûr française donc la
pression qui s'accentue sur le président
qui lui
pleinement soutenu par vladimir poutine
par la russie à suivre on va vous suivre
au cours des prochaines heures et les
prochains jours avec sandra
patrice les pressions aussi de la part
de moscou où on a déclaré qu'il faudrait
un pouvoir fort ici est clair à kiev
pour que la deuxième tranche des deux
soit versé et à
l'ukraine la deuxième tranche d aide que
vladimir poutine a promis 15 milliards
de dollars dont seulement deux ont été
versés jusqu'à date et vous savez que
l'ukraine est au bord de la faillite
alors cet argent là est très important
grosse grosse pression sur le président
ianoukovitch aujourd'hui la part de
l'europe et de la part de moscou
alexandre à chaska care mercy